professor at NYU has just suggested a
new course for students which is the
teaching of mating Dynamics we're
developing these digital analoges of
life that create low entry lowrisk
relationships life is about the victory
of taking risks enduring rejection and
quite frankly pursuing someone and
developing the skills and deciding to
put on a clean shirt and maybe shower
more often and maybe hit the gym every
once in a while every teenager in in
high school should have a course as part
of Health on mating Dynamics where they
teach especially young men that
approaching a woman and expressing
romantic interests while making her feel
safe is a skill and there's nothing
wrong with that and at the end game a
relationship a partner is one of the
keys to a happy life this guy is almost
totally right the only thing I disagree
with him on is the phrase mating
Dynamics is that makes us sound like
animals makes us sound like gorillas